with almost 500 sessions next 2019 it's
understandable that you can get to all
of them so if you didn't see cloud data
fusion data integration at Google cloud
then stay tuned because here is the
rewind the biggest barrier to enterprise
data analysis and machine learning is
data integration it is not uncommon to
see companies struggle to get their data
in one place move it around transform it
and make sense out of it because
honestly it's really hard problem to
solve cloud data fusion is a fully
managed cloud native data integration
service that helps users efficiently
build and manage data pipelines with the
graphical interface and a broad
open-source library of pre-configured
connectors and transformations data
fusion shifts and organizations focus
away from code and integration to
insights and action data Fusion is built
on the open source project seed app and
this open core ensures data pipeline
portability for users data fusion aims
at making the lives of data
practitioners easier by providing a
graphical user interface to visually
drag-and-drop elements to create data
pipelines and then finally run it on GCP
in data fusion we collect metadata
information on fields and tables and
expose them as lineage so you can do
root cause analysis and impact analysis
data fusion can solve a variety of use
cases if you are building a data
warehouse using bigquery you should look
at data fusion since it can connect to
multiple different data sources like
Oracle and other relational and
non-relational databases if you're
looking to retire a legacy system data
fusion can help you migrate the data to
GCP if you're looking to consolidate
data or in a hybrid environment you can
use data fusion for data consistency
across cloud and on-premise in
data fusion natively integrates with
Google cloud which simplifies data
security and ensures your data is
immediately available for analysis data
fusion offers both pre-configured
transformations from an OSS library as
well as the ability to create an
internal library of custom connections
and transformations that can be
validated shared and reused across an
organization it lays the foundation of
collaborative data engineering and
improves productivity this means less
waiting for data engineers and
importantly less sweating about code
quality if you'd like to see the full
talk and the demo check out the link in
the description below and don't forget
to subscribe to the cloud YouTube
channel for more great next rewind
content thank you for watching
[Music]